SPEAKER 1: So they
give you the picture
of how this data
platform puts together,
we're going to use a scenario
of an advertising agency
that puts ads in the back of
those screens in New York City
taxis.
If ever if you've been in
a cab recently in New York.
There's an ad that plays,
and you can interact with it.
To give you the
picture first, this
is a simplified architecture
of this data solution.
The taxis are sending their
position in real time.
Where they are in
the city, as well
as their destination, how
many passengers they have,
and what sort of interactions
the customers are doing.
Pub/Sub is then
ingesting that data.
We're using dataflow to
process a data pipeline.
To handle and process
all that data.
We're also archiving the
entire historical data
in BigQuery, which is a
really powerful tool for you
to do ad hoc analysis of
all of your historical data.
And at the end we want
to make a visualization.
So why don't we actually
see the pipeline in action.
So this the dataflow
visualization tool.
And you see Robert's
hovered-- we're
ingesting a little over
15,000 new elements per second
into this database, of
all of this information.
But how do you
visualize all that?
Google Maps is super
powerful, but I'd
hate to point 15,000 updates
per second at my Chrome browser.
So dataflow actually allows
us to down-sample that events
stream to give us a real
time visualization of taxi
positions.
And this is that visualization.
This is showing where all
these taxis are in New York
City at any given time.
Now what if I want to look at
one particular customer who's
placed ads with us.
A particular agency.
We can filter that dataflow,
and now the visualization
will update so that we're
only seeing ads that are being
placed for a specific store.
In this case, the Acme
store-- it looks like it's
on the Upper East Side.
And sure enough, we see that
we're placing ads, roughly,
geographically, near the store.
But right now, we're just
using a dumb rule for this.
It's just a very simple rule.
Where is the store?
Where's the taxi?
Place the ads.
Can we do better?
Can we automate this
to start to take
into account all the various
data that we have about this?
Well, let's start
by using BigQuery
to explore this dataset.
The query Robert has here looks
at all of the taxis coming
from the airports and tries
to see how many of them
are traveling near restaurants.
Now note here he's querying
this historical data,
even as we're ingesting new data
at 15,000 events per second.
So BigQuery gives
him the ability
to have an always up-to-date
real time view into his data.
In this case, we see that
roughly 17% of our taxis
are from the airport
and near a restaurant.
That sounds like an
insight that maybe we ought
to do some ad targeting there.
And if you look
at his query, you
can see it really is
a non-trivial query.
And BigQuery is handling
all that for us.
So right now, we are manually
configuring these ads.
So I think what we want
to do is look at a way
that we can do this in
an automatic fashion.
Now we could similarly search
for every different customer,
but how do we build a
generalizable and flexible
model.
Well that sounds like a
job for a machine learning.
Machine learning is
tailor-made for taking
large chunks of data
and building models
that give you
insights out of that.
So we're going to build a model
that takes into account all
of the data we have.
Where did the taxi start?
Where did it end?
How many people were in it?
What time of day is it?
Where's it going?
First, we're going
to start by using--
as you see in this picture--
we're going to use Dataprep.
To take all that
historical data,
clean it up, make sure
that it's ready to use,
and then we're going to
use it with ML engine.
So this is Dataprep.
The first thing to
notice is across the top,
Dataprep has automatically
inferred the schema
from my table.
I didn't have to tell it that.
Now if you look at that
passenger count column,
you'll notice that it
looks a little funny.
The histogram, up at the top,
includes some elements that
says there's 10 or 11 people.
Now, I don't know about you,
but I've been in a New York City
cab, and I'm pretty
sure you can't actually
put 10 or 11 people in a cab.
So that's a common data bug.
Dataprep allows me to fix
that in a number of ways.
I could delete the data.
I could replace that 11
with a one, on the theory
that it's a fat-finger mistake.
And Dataprep allows me to build
simple recipes that clean up
my entire data at scale.
It also can do things like-- if
you look at our location column
there, it's a composite column.
It's longitude and
latitude, comma separated.
I'd really like to have a
latitude column and a longitude
column.
Dataprep allows me to
build a recipe that
splits columns with Composite
data into separate columns.
So that I now have a
better schema to work with.
Now this just
scratches the surface
of how Dataprep can take this
really tedious job of preparing
data for analytics, and make
it much faster and much more
reliable.
Once we've done this,
machine learning,
as you heard from
[INAUDIBLE], allows
me to build a model on my
laptop, upload it to Google,
and deploy at scale.
Let's see how that
actually works.
If you scroll down in
the dataflow pipeline,
you'll see we've added
an ML engine call.
So now, as our taxi
data is coming in,
we're calling to machine
learning with the data
and saying, help us
choose the best ad
to target for this
particular user.
So let's switch
back over to the map
with the deployed
machine learning model,
and now you'll see
that we start seeing
some interesting combinations.
When there's one passenger
coming in towards midtown--
the taxi is currently in
Chelsea, and it's on its way
to midtown--
we're presenting an offer
for Manhattan Bagels.
Because it's a single
person, maybe he or she
wants a bite to eat.
If we pick a taxi that has
more than one person in it--
There it is.
In this case, that's
a one person one,
but they're heading into
a different location.
And instead we've
chosen a winery.
If you pick a taxi
with three people,
the system would automatically
recommend discounted tickets
to Broadway, for example--
as multiple people coming
to midtown in the evening.
So that's Cloud ML,
making suggestions based
on all our available data.
We used Pub/Sub to ingest a
huge stream of data at scale.
We use dataflow to build
a pipeline to give us
a good analytics system.
We used BigQuery
so that we always
had the complete
historical data available.
We never had to deal
with sample data.
And at the end, we use Cloud ML
and Dataprep to build and train
at scale a model.
What's important here
is what you didn't see.
I didn't deploy a
virtual machine.
I didn't deploy patches.
I spent my time
actually in the data.
That's the point of big data is
to spend the time in the data
and not in the machines
that take care of the data.
And that's what big data on
the Google platform does.
So I want to thank you all
and I'll turn it back over
to Brian.